[Music]
good morning I would like to acknowledge
that this school is situated upon
traditional territories
[Music]
we're paying respect to Aboriginal
people who were here before us and we're
trying to fix any wrongs we've done so
territories include the wind dot
initiative vaccinations the hood nashoni
Confederacy the Mississauga of the new
credit First Nation and the nomination
isn't it time that we acknowledge the
12,000 years that the indigenous people
have lived on this continent before we
sing old Canada when the Europeans
arrived they brought diseases that were
unfamiliar to life people we died by the
hundreds of thousands we weren't a
conquered the land wasn't purchased from
us and the treaties that were made where
most of them were broken so it's time
that we got this message out
[Music]
I also recognize the endearing presence
of aboriginal feedings
on this land the treaty that was signed
for this particular parcel of wizard is
collectively referred to as it's trying
to purchase now please stand Pro Canada
have a great day
[Music]